ja was hat es mit diesen Kampfdrohnen
auf sich die heute wieder so viel
Schrecken verbreiteten das möchte ich
eine ausgewiesene Expertin auf diesem
Gebiet Fragen Ulrike Franke
Sicherheitsexpertin vom European Kanzel
und von relations und ihr Spezialgebiet
sind neue kriegstechnologien
insbesondere Drohnen guten Abend Frau
Franke einen schönen guten Abend diese
Drohnen nennt man ja diese iranischen
die heute
über Kiew wieder am auftauchten und so
viel Leid verursachten nennt man ja auch
Kamikaze Drohnen können Sie uns etwas
näher erklären wie das funktioniert was
es damit auf sich hat
ja in der Tat also eigentlich sind diese
drohnensysteme gar keine wirkliche
Drohnen insofern als dass sie nicht
wiederverwertbar sind und deswegen
spricht man von
kamikazedonen oder auch sogenannter
herumlungernder Munition das sind
Systeme die werden in die Luft
geschossen können da eine Zeit lang
Kreisen können eine gewisse Reichweite
fliegen und stürzen sich dann auf ihr
Ziel und explodieren mit diesem Ziel
soll heißen sie sind eben nur einmal
verwertbar und können wie wir jetzt
gesehen haben von von Russland weit
entfernt von den Frontlinien eingesetzt
werden und der Terror verbreiten und das
hat meines Erachtens eigentlich den
größten Einfluss hier dieser Tage diese
Verbreitung des Terrors mit diesen
einmal verwendbaren Drohnen weil sie
sich eben auch gegen zivile Ziele
richten und weil sie ja von überall
herzukommen scheinen und wir aus dem
Nichts auftauchen
ja in der Tat der Punkt ist dass diese
Systeme von Trucks also von LKWs
gestartet werden können deswegen sind
sie sehr verlegefähig und können
überall mehr oder minder eingesetzt
werden und sie haben eine erstaunlich
weiter Reichweite die sie iranischen
Systeme und daher ist Russland eben in
der Lage auch weit entfernt von den
Frontlinien anzugreifen und deswegen
auch dieses Gefühl zu verbreiten dass
die Ukraine die Ukraine nirgendwo mehr
sicher sind und das hat sicherlich einen
psychologischen Einfluss macht im
übrigen natürlich auch die Bekämpfung
dieser Systeme schwieriger weil man ja
überall gleichzeitig gucken muss und das
bindet Kräfte und ist auch praktisch
einfach eigentlich so nicht nicht
wirklich möglich sie sagen diese
Bedrohungen sich dagegen zu wehren das
ist schwierig gibt es denn überhaupt
schon Systeme bei denen man weiß dass
die funktionieren ist jetzt viel die
Rede davon Mensch wir Deutschen wir
haben doch ihre C so heißt sein
Luftverteidigungssystem geliefert andere
werden genannt aber so einfach scheint
es nicht zu sein oder
ja ich sag immer drohnenabwehr ist
schwierig und einfach gleichzeitig also
einfach insofern als das Drohnen in der
Regel relativ langsam fliegen relativ
niedrig fliegen die sind auch nicht
besonders geschützt oder versteckt also
Tarnkappen Technik ist da in der Regel
kein großes Thema es sollte also einfach
sein sie vom Himmel zu holen
gleichzeitig ist es aber schwierig denn
man muss diese Systeme entdecken und
zwar rechtzeitig entdecken und das ob
der Tatsache dass die meisten
Radarsysteme einfach nicht dafür gebaut
sind diese kleinen Drohnen zu entdecken
dann gibt es auch noch ganz verschiedene
Systeme wir reden jetzt gerade über ein
System was heute die letzten Tage in der
Ukraine viel eingesetzt wurde aber der
Iran hat zum Beispiel auch andere Bohnen
geliefert also auch das ist relativ
schwierig und dann muss man eben ja im
richtigen Moment vor Ort sein das ganze
soll noch kosteneffizient sein denn man
will ja nicht quasi mit Kanonen auf
Spatzen schießen also diese Drohnen
Kosten vielleicht mehrere zehntausend
Euro oder Dollar das ist jetzt nicht so
viel wie viele Abwehr und das macht es
wiederum schwierig und es ist in der Tat
so dass die Ukraine ja Abwehrsysteme hat
und die Ukraine sagt auch dass sie
wirklich dutzende dieser Drohnen schon
abgeschossen hat sehr erfolgreich das
ist recht beeindruckend und da kann man
alles mögliche verwenden also was ich
jetzt gesehen habe heute waren
schultergestützte Systeme sogenannte
manpads der Gepard scheint wohl auch zum
Einsatz gekommen zu sein ihres Tier habe
ich jetzt noch nicht gehört das könnte
vielleicht etwas überdimensioniert sein
S300 also es gibt verschiedene
Abwehrsysteme aber es ist halt doch
nicht so einfach und wenn eine oder
mehrere durchkommen können sie eben
Schaden anrichten Frau Franke danke für
die Expertise und die Einordnung